significa colina humeante en lengua
náhuatl y es uno de los volcanes más
monitoreados del mundo por su alta
actividad el Popocatépetl a sólo 72
kilómetros de Ciudad de México ha estado
cada vez más activo durante la última
semana rocas candentes y grandes
columnas de gas están siendo expulsados
al aire lo que llevó al gobierno
mexicano a Elevar el nivel de alerta
amarillo 3 desplegando equipos de
Protección Civil en tres estados para
ayudar a planear una eventual evacuación
si llega a concretarse una erupción
[Música]
en esta localidad del estado de Puebla
la ceniza invadió las calles y veredas
pues muchas ceniza ahorita y es cuando
el campo se trabaja y pues no lo puede
uno hacer Por ese motivo de que está
cayendo muchas cenizas estaba muy activo
anoche estaba retumbando
este estaba aventando muchas cenizas y
este
estaba casi prendido
la actividad volcánica del Popo como es
conocido popularmente afectó la
operación de aeropuertos como el Benito
Juárez de la capital mexicana que detuvo
sus vuelos durante más de cinco horas el
sábado sin embargo la secretaría general
de gestión de riesgos informó Este
martes que se ha podido observar una
disminución del contenido de ceniza en
las últimas emanaciones
el Popocatépetl se despertó en 1994
después de décadas de inactividad desde
entonces ha registrado varias erupciones
sin causar víctimas mortales